companies have been trying to increase
the efficiency and productivity using
artificial intelligence to operate
autonomous vehicles in a trustworthy
manner so how can ai be used to operate
safely and effectively and how do you
leverage ai to do more than simply just
take the wheel let's find out in this
edition of the ai training ground
now one manufacturer is transforming
agriculture with an ai-powered
autonomous tractor this tractor is not
only self-driving but it can also
calculate and apply the optimal value of
herbicide thanks to onboard computer
vision
when done right farmers can turn to
these automated machines to treat plant
conditions with precision which not only
benefits the environment and reduces
cost it allows farmers to be more
efficient with their own time
computer vision can distinguish healthy
crops from failing crops it can analyze
soil conditions pest infestations and
understand weather conditions these are
all things it takes to manage a farm
but this only works if the ai model
powering it is properly trained with
data integrated from across multiple
disparate sources and without a data
fabric that can operate seamlessly
across multiple environments a lot can
go wrong
trusting the ai starts with trusting the
quality of the data it collects when
using image recognition you need to
establish an appropriate ground truth
through a large cleansed and secure data
set for model training for example are
the images used to train a model
correctly labeled and identifying the
right features if not the ai model won't
generate accurate outputs you can act on
and trust
we've all experienced geospatial data
with our smartphones where our moving
bubble on a map can range from pinpoint
precision to a whole city block
now consider our farmers if that
real-time geospatial data is even off by
a foot in a field it could damage or
destroy crops it could endanger the
lives of people or it could even lead to
a 10-ton tractor roaming the hillsides
having robust data to understand the
totality of the environment is critical
for autonomous vehicles of any kind to
operate safely and effectively this
includes topographical databases
combined with aerial imagery and
satellite imagery as well as weather
information and measurements collected
by onboard sensors
in this case the robustness of the data
and the robustness of the analytical
capabilities of the ai are key
in the end if users can't trust ai as
much as they trust their own judgment
they won't adopt the technology
learn more about building a strong data
foundation for trustworthy ai with ibm's
ai training ground
you